les visages fermés et pas décidé les
plus grands dirigeants européens réunis
à bruxelles l'union européenne
à la croisée des chemins celui du
compromis ou celui d'une crise majeure
les vingt-sept ont choisi l'unité le
plan de relance européen historique
décidée en juillet entre aujourd'hui
dans le concret nous venons d'adopter un
accord robuste sur le mécanisme à mettre
en oeuvre dans le respect de l'état de
droit
l'europe avance unis et porte ces
valeurs
les dirigeants européens n'ont pas tardé
à débloquer ce jeudi le plan de relance
posco vide estimé à 750 milliards
d'euros votée l'été dernier un accord
dont s'est réjoui le président du
conseil européen
charles michel maintenant nous pouvons
lancer la mise en oeuvre et reconstruire
nos économies
notre plan de relance historique va
faire avancer nos transition verte et
numérique une année 2020 a oublié et des
perspectives à construire pour l'avenir
les contours du budget de l'union
européenne pour les sept prochaines
années
finalement dessiner la hongrie et la
pologne réticente souhaitait éviter
toute condition arbitraire pour un
versement des fonds alpha une fois de
nos jour d'hui nous nous battons pour
l'unité de notre continent commun à nous
devons nous comporter de manière
raisonnable et trouver un moyen
d'adopter des approches fiable et de
faire triompher le bon sens pour fournir
des services de santé en cas de pandémie
aux personnes qui en ont besoin et pour
apporter une aide financière aux pays
qui sont réellement dans le besoin pour
aider leurs populations sisters forte
dose quand ces soirées dîners tour abda
flipo l'environnement également au coeur
des négociations
l'allemagne insiste notamment pour
réduire des émissions de co2 d'au moins
25% d'ici 2030 et atteindre la
neutralité climatique d'ici 2050 un
objectif collectif est actuellement à
l'étude